on the invitation and estimation of
dynamic structure models but more
importantly this paper is actually about
it I'll observe the choices which I
won't Amy don't explain what is it means
okay any of your common with the eval
will be greatly appreciated so to
motivate the paper me first let's think
about in a review preference framework
we typically assume that the choices
made by the agents are their optimal
decisions and hence reflecting some of
their own aligned preferences so because
of that the choices are usually
considered as one of the key ingredients
for our economic analysis right well the
aegis decisions unfortunately in reality
may not be always directly or perfectly
observed by researchers and there are
multiple reasons why this is the case
right so first of all if you think about
Amara has a problem and what I mean by
Marv hazard here is essentially there
exists information asymmetry between an
agent and a principal so an agent has
his own incentives to maximize some
objective functions but these they
choose their best action but these
actions could potentially impose
externalities on the other party which
is the principle but the principle
unfortunately may not be able to fully
monitor what is going on from agents
perspective right to give you a couple
of concrete examples in one of my other
paper I was studying the online credit
markets where borrowers and vendors are
interacting repeatedly over time so in
that context borrowers are the agents
once they receive the monitor transfer
from lenders they basically have
incentives to maybe invest in riskier
projects or they may have they may do
whatever they like with the money in
order to maximize their own payoffs but
these behaviors cannot be easily
monitored by lenders and it's even going
to be more difficult for us as
econometricians to know what exactly go
know from a borrower's perspective so
another example it's really to a
political economy where you can imagine
that there is a politician for example
it's a governor
he or she knows exactly the amount of
time or effort he spent in order to
promoting economic growth but this
information is very unlikely to be
observed by voters or it's also pretty
unlikely to be observed by us as a
researcher astray so another reason why
sometimes it may be very difficult to
obtain the agent's choices could be
related to the data collecting issues
for example it now makes a lot of
empirical questions or answer using
survey data but in many of the surveys
some of the key decisions of the
individual say their investment
decisions their human capital on child
development or say their healthcare
stuff like that may not be reported by
the agent because of the concern of the
privacy or in some other cases these
questions may not even be asked in a
survey because of the design of the
survey so there are multiple reasons why
actually a reality it may be actually
difficult for other researchers to
observe agents choices given the
situation the main research question of
this paper it's basically trying to
understand when the actions are hidden
from researchers perspective what we can
do in order to still uncover this
decision-making process and to infer
some of the preference parameters of the
agents in other - from the data in order
to do further analysis such as
counterfactuals right in order to do
that we have to think about what kind of
modeling assumptions we need to impose
and what time the data variations will
all be using in order to recover the
preference of the agents even if their
choices are not observed ok so that's a
nun question of this paper we can take a
quick look at existing literature on the
dynamic these clear choice models so
first of all there is a long list of
this kind of empirical work but for most
of the majority of them the research
papers are focused on the cases in which
choices are observables you can think of
the grass type and your replacement
decisions by individuals
retirement decision occupational choices
all of these kind of informations are
known to the researchers when they do
this work ok
from a more theoretical perspective if
we think about the application of
dynamic squared choice models all of the
papers are listed here study the
theoretical results for the invocation
of structural parameters but all of
these actually require the observation
of agents choices and some state
variable for a set of random agent and
for a period of time right and if we
think about estimation in the literature
there are two main strands of the
literature the first one is called so
called the nest a fixed point algorithm
which is proposed by rust and the other
one it's initiated by Hudson Miller in
1983 which is kind of us so 2-step
mechanic two-step estimation strategy
well in either of these two types of
estimation strategies agents choices are
needed
you need the choice to either construct
a likelihood to do the estimation or in
a CCP type of the two-step method you
have to use the choice to do some non
parametric estimation of the choice
probabilities or the state transition
probabilities in the first step using
the raw data and then you can take that
as given to your second step in order to
estimate some more deep structural
parameters right so basically to
summarize the existing approaches are
not generally effective when this
variable choice variables are not
observed of econometrician and so for
our paper the main target is basically
to solve this problem by providing more
structures okay
so specifically what we do in this paper
is to provide new and invocation and
estimation methods for that I'm a
discrete choice models when the agents
actions are not observed in our baseline
analysis we consider a very simple
standard single agent fine and horizon
dynamics quick first model and with the
continuous state variable and we specify
state transition process through a
nonparametric regression model plus some
hardware which I will be more specific
when I talk about model we consider
couple of extensions to our baseline
results for example we can allow that
there exist some serial correlated
observations ie which is also not
observed
electricians we can also allow for an
infinite horizon model but we definitely
need more information for that case we
also consider a more practical scenario
where maybe we don't have a continuous
t-square continuous a variable so what
if if there are only these crazy verbs
are available then what can we do about
it okay so the last but not the list of
our extension we want to show that
actually our an invocation tuition it's
not limited only to a single agent
Dunham's a discrete choice models so we
show that a similar kind of idea could
be apply to deal with the dynamic these
quick games of incomplete information
even if the choices are not observing
that case ok so I will be mostly talking
about the last extension because it was
time constraints
following our invocation strategy we
propose a safe maximum likelihood
estimator in order to estimate a non
parametric functions in a state
transition process and also the agency
utility parameters we also conduct Monte
Carlo simulations in order to examine
the finance sample proposes of our
proposed estimator I so this part is a
little bit more like technical and
relate to more econometrics rather than
intuition of verification so I don't
think I have time to go through the
details but in general our estimator
actually works pretty well so that's
kind of the pumps life ok but if I have
time I can show you some results so we
also try to apply our method to actual
empirical setting we basically try to
study the moral hazard problems in the
US government or elections specifically
we get a data set from another paper
which is collecting information on
governor's in the United States from
1950 to the 2000 and we basically
estimate a dynamic disc waitress model
or governor's effort exerting decision
so basically our model the governor is
the agent case has a decision to think
about whether or not I'm going to exert
effort or I'm just going to shirk right
these decisions for is of course not
observed by us but these decisions will
have impact
um the status of the economy for example
which will will have some measure for
that and we estimated model try to think
about what are the utility preferences
of the governors and how that affect
their choices okay the quick results
basically we find that indeed as the
governors are approaching the end of the
term they basically there is a
significant higher chance that they will
exert less effort and we also find some
heterogeneity which I will explain after
I show you the bottom okay
this empirical application it's related
to some work in the political economy a
lot of paper I started here basically
try to study the impact of the
institutional design of election rules
for example the I want to understand
what is the impact of term limits on
politicians
performances and our paper here
basically trying to also study this
question by using a more structural
method but we will see the results later
okay so this is all line for the rest of
the talk as I said I will first start
with a very simple single agent and I
made this clear choice model and it
gives you some basic idea about how it
works okay so in the baseline results we
are thinking about a single agent
animated shorts model but with a final
horizon and we use T to be the index for
each time periods and cap T is the last
period a cup of notations so in a paper
we use s T to be the observed state so
it the state variable is observed from
econometrician point of view but we also
have this epsilon T to represent of
their state which is only observed by
the agent but is not observed by us
econometricians and the examples of this
epsilon T could be just some it's early
shocks
okay so throughout the paper we're going
to use Y T to represent agents choices
which is an endogenous object basically
the agent will solve his own
optimization problem to decide whether
or not to exert effort okay
in each period we can write down the
agents flow utility we
essentially depends on the realization
of the state variables those observed
and observed and also the choice he made
and given the structure we can write
down the sum of the discount utility
swimming up the agent like this which is
pretty straightforward and here we use
beta to denote that these come factor of
a yes could be multiple but I will
mostly focus on the binary case just for
illustration okay
so beta is a discount factor and
throughout the paper we are going to
assume that we know beta and this is
also the typical results in the Carver
literature that it's unless you have
additional restriction it's hard to
identify the discount factor so given a
model we can the agents problem is
basically to choose some decision rule
in order to maximize the expectation of
the discount of some of the discount
values here the expectation is of course
taken with respect to the transition
process of the state variable and also
the choices but this transition process
is also induced by the discipline so the
optimal decision is basically choose a
vector of Delta for each period in a
fine and horizon game okay so at this
point we're going to impose the
following assumption in order to
restrict our attention to a certain type
of that model first of all we are going
to assume that the dynamic process of
the state variable and choice variable
satisfy this the first solid Markov
process so this is typically a adopted
in the literature but it could be
generalized in our to allow for higher
order Markov process okay and we also
following the literature the the ross
paper that which is seminal paper in the
literature to impose the following
conditional independence assumption on
the state transition process and there
are two implications for for this
conditional independence assumption
first of all conditional on your current
state the realization of your it slowly
flux will be independent over time okay
and more than that the transition for
your observed state variable depends on
you are stay variable in the last period
but also depend on choice but it's
independent
of your utility shocks in the previous
period okay that helps to reduce a lot
of dimensionality issue and which is
typically also induced adopted in the
empirical literature but of course this
conditional independence assumption it's
restrictive and there are some more
recent work trying to relax that by
allowing this Epsilon's to be serially
correlated and in in our main an
application results because we want to
highlight that if the identification
with respect to other choices rather
than these complicated structure of the
Epsilon's so we want to stick with this
more restrictive conditional
independence independence assumption for
our baseline results but later we can
show that actually we can take our model
to a more complicated situation where
the serial correlated heterogeneity is
its incorporated okay the last part of
our assumption one basically states that
the state transition rules are timing
invariant so no matter you are at your
early Paris or the ending periods this
one is always going to be the same and
this assumption is also typically
imposed and if you do observe agents
choices in the data set you can
basically test that but in our case
because we don't observe our choices so
this is assumption we have to make and
people have using assumption a lot also
in the literature okay given our model
we can write down represent the agents
optimization problem using this balanced
equation in a recursive way and
specifically because we assume that the
utility shocks in the last period will
not affect the realization of the future
states that's why in this last term the
conditional expectation of the value
function does not its the Epsilon's does
not enter into here okay given the value
function
the agents decision is basically simply
choose a Y which is the choice in order
to maximize the value and from the
decision rule if we integrate over the
distribution of the Epsilon's
conditional state we can basically
derive the probability that
alternatives why is chosen conditional
on the state and this is the so-called
conditional choice probabilities which
is also typically in a literature called
sec peace and these are important
equilibrium okay and notice that in our
CC piece we have this subscript T in
there because this is a final Horizon
model and in a final Horizon model when
you make your decisions it's potentially
non stationary you will make different
decisions at the early period versus
ending Paris because the same centers
are different okay okay so this is the
basic setup of the model so in in this
slide I'm basically trying to show you a
kind of graphical illustration about a
dynamic process of the state variable
and the choice variable that is
consistent with our assumption so here
because the whole point of this talk
it's about unobserved choices so in
order to highlight that I just like add
a asterisk to the Y in order to indicate
that this is how observe how many
combinations point of view okay so
basically what we see in this structure
it's essentially two things the first
part is highlighted in this yellow
triangle which is saying that my current
state depends on my state in the last
period it also depends on my choices in
the last period and this whole thing in
this triangle basically tells us
information about a state transition
rules okay
and the second part which is highlighted
in this blue circle it is basically
talks about conditional on my carbon
state then I'm gonna make some choices
and in the data you will be able to see
the conditional choice for it directly
if you do see the choices okay so to
make it simple basically if this is why
the choices are observed from
econometricians point of view though we
can estimate these two parts directly
from the data
nonparametric or parametric whatever you
like and this is exactly the key point
in the hot sand mailer type of the
method so you ask them mate these
equilibrium objects from the data in a
first step and you take them to your
second staff as if they are known and
you can match that you can solve the
optimization problem to match with this
equilibrium objects in order to
that called more deeper structural
utility parameters well in our case
because we don't observe the agents
winces so neither of them can be
estimated from the data so which means
the original typical solution to this
type of a model will not work and this
is the main challenging for our case if
the choices are not observed okay
however even if this two are not cannot
be directly observed from the data it
doesn't mean that these two are
completely irrelevant right so these two
objects are still inherently connecting
with each other
which with each other through this
observe state transition process so we
don't observe the choices but we do
observe some state variables us right
and to put it in the in the formula so
basically on the left hand side of this
equation this is a density of state as
prime is realized conditional that the
previous state is s and this one can be
written as a mixture of the two
latent transition probabilities well the
choice probability the probability that
each alternative is chosen can be
basically think of as like a mixture
weight right so essentially we do not
observe these terms separately but we do
observe these state transition process
from the data and then the edification
problem for for this paper is basically
reduced to how to use the observed state
transition process in the data to
recover these unknown
parts from the model and if we know the
transition process and the choice
probabilities then we can just follow
the hata mirrors the type of the
estimation strategy to do whatever we
need but the first step is basically how
to identify these two from yeah
only ass bite when that inside that is
like non-degenerate like in the bus
replacement yes right so you know in the
in the last type of model this one
actually doesn't really have a like
important meaning because I so even if I
don't observe your choice I know the
mileage becomes zero if you replace
energy right so it doesn't really so in
our case we're more thinking about so
suppose there is an agent like a
governor she's he or she is choosing an
effort that after will have some
stochastic impact on the state variable
but we cannot fully recover their
choices yes but you are definitely right
you directly you can tell the choices so
you don't need to exactly yes okay okay
so this is the identification problem
we're going to solve now let me talk
about like more detail a little bit more
details okay but before that let me
still keep trying to give you some
intuition in order to see what's the
main variations in the data we're gonna
be using in order to identify other
parameters so for illustration let's
think about there are a sequence of time
periods from period one to cap T and
there are there are two periods along
the dynamic process which is very tall
and T and talk arrives earlier than okay
so let's assume that at these two
periods the realization of the state
variable are exactly the same which is s
okay then if we now add P R at all
suppose we move one period for the we
can write down the conditional
distribution of the future state
conditional as tall equals to us okay
and this is just as I explained in the
last slide is basically just a mixture
of the true latent state transition
probabilities oh and and the choice
probabilities are just some mixture
weights and you can do exactly the same
thing for
purity okay it depends on it depends on
because there's a finite horizon model
yes so that's why here it's uh yeah I I
didn't have a subscript but this is a
white tie and this is like okay so from
our previous assumptions while we have
imposed assumption that the state
transition rules are timing variant
which means no matter you are at parity
or period talk these two terms are gonna
be exactly the same however in a final
horizon model the probability that an
alternative is trolden is gonna be
different
which means this red part and the blue
part they are going to be different and
because of that they generate
differences in terms of the observe
state variables right so put it in other
way for an invocation if we see the
differences in the observed state
transition process at two period like
two periods of time then we know that
these differences are not coming from
the state transition probabilities per
se but it's actually coming from the
differences in the choice probabilities
which will be governed by some deep into
the parameters right so that's kind of
the key intuition for ratification and
if you put in another way you can think
of in a final horizon model time is very
important so time it's sort of like a
exclusion restriction because time only
affects your choice probabilities but it
does not affect your state transition
probabilities so that kind of exclusion
restriction kind of play a very
important role but if you think about
this is an infinite horizon model then
the time will not be an exclusion
restriction because the choice probably
won't be stationary over time and for
that case you we actually need some
additional exclusion restrictions that
may only affect the the choices
probabilities but not affect the state
transition probability so that's kind of
one of our extension but exclusion
restriction important and final horizon
time naturally it serves as a sushi
restriction okay
in our panel we basically assume that
assume some structure on the state
transition process so we assume that
this st plus 1 equals to the summation
of two parts and the first part it's a
nonparametric regression model well
which is function M and it's an unknown
function and it could be very flexible
but it depends on your choices in the
last period and also your state variable
in the last period and we don't know the
shape of M in a model we don't have to
know that okay and it also adds up this
ETA which represents some random shocks
that effects a state transition process
and we assume that these random shocks
are independent of the observed choice
condition on a state variable and for a
normalization purposes we assume that
the conditional mean of the ETA which is
the random shock equals to 0 we form the
previous assumption while we know that
the state transition process does not
change over time and given that
structure this is basically also implies
that ETA has a stationary distribution
you the the distribution of ETA cannot
also change over time bye-bye
so for illustration now let's consider
the an invocation for some fixed state s
and again for illustration I'm assuming
that the agent can only take binary
choice either 1 or 0 okay and under this
very specific case basically to identify
the unknown functions and basically it's
reduced to identify two numbers which is
M 1 and M 0 and they are the values for
the UM functions given that the choices
are one versus zero and when a state is
fixed at us okay we can also define the
choice probabilities at these to appear
at two periods T and tau we use PT and
Peter to denote the probability that one
is chosen okay so that's just some
notations we also construct some
conditional moments of the observed
state variables for example we use Milty
to cost to be the first other
conditional moments on the state
variable new and excited be the second
and third order so all of these
conditional moments of the state
variables are purely based on the
observed state so they can be directly
estimated using the data for an
invitation purposes we can just treat
them as if we already know them and
they're just some constants we can get
from the data okay okay now to think
about identification
so remember mutti it's the first order
conditional mean of the state variable
which could be written as the following
question where we are basically
replacing future as t plus 1 by our
structure which is some n function plus
and epsilon plus 1/8 at home okay and
remember that by assumption two we know
this ETA it's independent of the
observed choices so which means we can
basically get this either term out of
the summation right and we also make the
normalization assumption that the
conditional taxation of eta is 0 which
means that part
just go away in the first other
conditional moment and essentially we
can rewrite our first other conditional
mean of the state variable as a weighted
average of M 1 and M 0 and the weights
are just the probability that one is
chosen versus zeros frozen ok and you
can do exactly the same thing for purity
and pure it's huh and this is the two
equations after do that and from this
two equation the key observation is that
if you know I'm 1 and M 0 then you can
solve for P you can solve for the choice
probabilities as long as this M 1 is not
equal to 0 because if they're equal then
there's no way to distinguish which is a
higher state versus a motorcy ok so then
our invocation problem is basically to
think about how to recover this on 1 and
i'm 0 which is the key parameters in the
state transition process if we do know
that then we can easily pack all our
choice
so this is the first order conditional
moment then if we think about the higher
other conditional moments of the state
variable this procedure is very similar
but now the only thing is that in the
equation we get this term which is I
highlighted in red this is basically the
higher order conditional moments of the
error term which is ETA right and unlike
the first order case we can basically
know that the condition is 0 by
normalization but now in this higher
order moments we actually don't know
what's the value of these conditional
expectation of mita right and that's
basically introduce more unknowns to our
system if we want to pin down what is
the value of 1 1 & 0 and if you keep
using higher higher order moments again
you will still never know the unknowns
for conventional moment okay but now
recall that we have argue that the
conditional distribution of ETA is
stationary which means that no matter
you are out purity and here at all these
conditional moments of the error terms
will remain the same
so from this observation it's easy to
think of that now we can just use the
variation look for different time
periods in order to get rid of this time
and this is exactly what we are gonna do
next okay so basically what we do is to
take a difference between this
second-order and third-order moments of
the observed state to get rid of the
ITA's and now this equation even though
it looks quite complicated it's still
only incorporated a couple of things so
on the left hand side that's some the
differences between some observables and
on the right hand side it involves these
choice probabilities which are in red
and involves the M 1 and M 0 which some
unknown parameter of interest and it
also involves these meals which are also
the known constant from the data okay
but also remember that from this lights
we have to arrive the formula for the
choice probabilities as long as we know
M 1 and M 0 we can pack up P okay so if
we take that formula
to this two equations makes basically
the peas are called so everything
remains is just M 1 M 0 and some known
constant from the data so that basically
gave us our two equations two nonlinear
equations of M 1 and M 0 but there are
only two unknowns which are M 1 and 0
and in the next slides I'm basically
going to show that given a system we can
actually got a closed form solution for
M 1 and M 0 which is kind of very nice
if you want to do the estimation that it
constructed so if we call the summation
and the product of M 1 and M 0 to be
delta1 and delta2 then you can do like a
very basic maybe high school algebra to
derive the formula for Delta 1 and Delta
2 it looks like ugly but essentially
it's on the right-hand side it's
everything you can just use the observed
conditional moments of the state
variable nothing nothing you and if you
know Delta 1 and Delta 2 basically M 1
and M 0 there are just two solutions to
this quadratic form equation provided
that it does have two solutions and also
the two solutions are not equal to each
other and these conditions here is also
testable just using the data okay so
then you get two numbers from two
solutions to this quadratic equation and
then the only remaining stuff you want
to understand is that which is zero and
which is M 1 right any question okay so
there are many different so basically in
order to decide which one is M 0 which
one is my you have to impose some
ordering conditions right from the data
you can directly tell which one is which
because they are associated with some
unknown choices so you don't know which
one is which so in our paper we propose
one example which can be used to tell
you the differences between M 1 0 which
is suppose y equals to 1 means that the
agent exert effort and why cuz the zero
means that they don't then we can assume
that conditional agent works hard the
state distribution the future
state distribution first other
stochastic a dominants the one where
agent does not work hard so this is just
one example that tells you that if this
is the case the one is larger than zero
but you can come up with any other other
conditions according to the that you are
empirical application so it doesn't
really matter how you tell the
difference between on one answer and
also it doesn't really matter if you can
always switch the order of these two and
label them one of one of them okay so
once we identify this M one and M zero
then we can basically recover the twist
probably use that very simple phone over
three so you can use it so if they're
overlapping you need you need three yes
will you do your estimation yes you can
use them all together and to estimate
which yes and you can potentially also
test using this over anything
restrictions so now we have kinder M one
and M 0 and then we we know PT and PETA
the other thing we don't know so far is
the conditional distribution of the
error term ETA because we know the
conditional mean zero but we don't know
really the shape of the ETA so in order
to recover that we can write down the
transition state transition process of
the observe variable but using the
conditional distribution of the ETA so
here we're basically evaluate the
conditional density of ETA at s prime
minus m1 and s prime minus M 0 and this
weights are still the choice
probabilities ok
again the stationarity of the ETA
distribution place is super important
role because given that we know that
these conditional densities will be the
same across different areas but the
choice probabilities are not and we
already know what is their choice but
what are the choice probabilities so
from these two equations you can solve
for this red term and the blue
and if you use different value of us
prime then you can basically trace out
the conditional density function for
each at different values you have you if
you have more well like if you Y
increases basically you know you will
get more unknowns like I'm wonder I'm
I'm too and like then you will get a
larger system of nonlinear equations you
yes
okay now we have already also pinned
down the distribution of ETA and this is
basically just a summary of what I have
just said given that I only have five
minutes left so I watch a skip as I
expect about this estimation and similar
results but essentially what we're doing
it's similar to maximum likelihood but
it's not exactly the same because our
estimations have to deal with this non
parametric functions of an and also non
distribution of ETA which is also non
parametric our case and we instead used
to see if maximum likelihood which is
basically you are kind of using some
approximating like polynomials or some
other basis functions to approximate a
non parametric functions and I'm happy
to talk about that part offline if
you're interested okay oh sorry this is
I want to talk about the one of the
extensions we got in this paper
basically it's about the dynamic screams
of incomplete information so in our
setting previously we're focusing on the
single agent model but consider now we
have a game and I index for each
individual so suppose these players
choose an action from action set
simultaneously at each period and we use
this bold Y to be the action profile and
suppose each player at each period
observe their state variable which is
also publicly observed by other players
and also observed by competitions
epsilon t denote the utility shock which
is only privately observed by the agent
but not by any other players not by us
also okay I don't like the single agent
game now the agents utility depends off
not only my information but also
depending on other people's choices and
other people's state and here this s and
why they are both are because that
represents a profile of the actions and
states it's infinite because this T
could be going to infinity yes but it
also should apply for the financer Iser
but I'm just thinking infinite horizon
is more general okay so we consider a
pure strategy Markov perfect with a firm
of the of the game and we define the
player ice equilibrium choice
probability conditional a state profile
as this p star so if the a destroy
Cesare actually observed by
econometricians then you can use a very
similar two-step method which has been
discussed in the literature for a while
you can basically recover this
equilibrium choice probability from the
data directly and ask me the transitions
other state also from the data and then
you take that which is a equilibrium
object into the second step to estimate
other utility parameters well in our
case we do not observe agent choices so
we have to make some additional
assumptions in order to recover in order
to recover the parameters so typically
we're assuming that we impose additional
structure on the state transition
process we're assuming that condition
along the curve value of a often players
action nana states the future states are
independent across pointers so this
assumption basically it's motivated by
some empirical setting in the dynamic
oligopoly computation so if you can
think about that the state variable is
my capacity level the choices is just my
incremental choices to change this to
capacity then what is my future capacity
looks like doesn't really depend on
other people's choices or other states
it only depends on my choice and my
previous state okay and if that is the
case you can think about for player I
this is the state transition process
it's a mixture of the latent state
transition process and also the mixture
of the that makes the weight sister
choice probabilities by assumption we
assume that this part only depends on my
own state but in the game setup the
choice probability well naturally
depends on everybody else
state so in the game setting basically
the s- iso other people's state
variables will be serving as an
exclusion restriction so this is kind of
like what I find
kind of interested in natural in the
game side up and if you have this kind
of exclusion restriction then you can do
whatever similar in our basement model
to identify the choice probably the I
say transition process so i okay two
minutes okay let me just quickly talk
about our impure classification which I
have already said a little bit so we
have this data for governors and
basically in our after we cloning the
data we essentially have a hundred and
forty two governors and they are called
the lame ducks from using some jargon in
a political economy so basically when
what this means is that these governors
are not eligible for reelection and
there are two possible cases for that so
in some cases in some states basically
all the governors are allowed to only be
on a team office for four years in some
other states it could be multiple could
be at least at most two consecutive
terms and each term is four years and
for that cases we only incorporate the
governor's who are who were serving
their second term the reason we do that
is basically to get rid of this
reelection incentives in the agent state
in the governor's organization problem
just to make things simple but
definitely readings great election
incentives it's important okay so we
have some observed activists of the
governor we also observe this log of per
capita spending which we use as a
indicator for the like how well the
economy is doing for the state and I
don't have time to show you the details
but we're using it's just basically
taking our baseline model saying that
the state variable follows the
transition follows that structure and we
have a very simple linear utility
function for the governor's choices we
got estimates and we also try to compute
the probability that a governor is
shirking for year one which is the time
that he or she got it re-elected and for
is the period that he will leave the
office and we do find that as the
governor's are approaching me and they
basically more likely to exert to shirk
and we also find that for people who
were serving their second term
compared to their first terms are more
like cost-effective that which is kind
of interesting because you can imagine
that people who got reelected may be
inherently different from those who just
got the first term because they already
survived the first term and they got
really lactate and this is we call the
selection effect of the elections and
yeah so this is everything I want to
talk about thanks so much in government
for example you can yeah it could be
something like that or you can think
about change their incentive schemes or
[Music]
change their like after they leave the
office change their like I don't know
changed or so for example if they care
more about the future after they leave
the office what they cannot do or
something like that their career
concerns stuff like that
in our modest exoticness but you have to
understand the agents like utility of
preferences in order to do that cutter
photos which is actually not typically
done in the exact center of this
particular economy because they are
mostly using more regression analysis
thank you